foreign
good afternoon everyone
my name is Dr Miller and the SCP we're
going to be looking at today is SCP
1348. object class
ketter
special containment procedures
due to the impossibility of Transport
scp-1348 is contained on site at the
site-87 archaeological containment unit
81 kilometers southeast of eltama Syria
in the Jamal aldruz mountains
compartmentalized containment Duties are
assigned to see 1348-a Team a and c1348b
Team B with the exception of bi-weekly
containment review meetings between site
director bin Yaman Khan and Team B
director Communications between teams A
and B are to only occur in conference
room 2A
to minimize the risk of
cross-contamination all inter team
Communications related to Ritual
standards and performances must be
conducted via staff member belonging to
Y chromosomal haplotype cmh-6
containment team a shall be comprised of
foundation employees recommended by
class 4 cites supervisory Personnel
subject to disqualification for the
following reasons
present membership in a religious faith
prior exposure to a registered memetic
agent
fluency in Amharic guise Aramaic or any
Southern Semitic language
and prior exposure to Transmissions from
SCP
team a duties include providing ritual
supplies necessary to perform
scp-1348 II monitoring Team B and
civilian celebrants for compliance
selecting celebrants for participation
in ritual containment providing updated
protocols for daily performances of
scp-1348-2 monitoring members of Team B
during furloughs from the containment
area and developing and executing
protocol 228 melica
at no time shall Personnel involved in
228 Malika be exposed to recordings or
transcripts of scp-1348 II enter
scp-1348-3 or be permitted to view the
remains of
scp-1348-1 E
candidates for containment Team B shall
be selected from individuals
matrilineally descended from Drew's
mandian and Mizrahi Jewish populations
membership in y chromosomal haplotype
cmh-6 is strictly disqualifying
due to practical difficulties in
locating suitable candidates in
Foundation employment class Omega
civilian celebrants with appropriate
genealogy may be substituted for
foundation personnel with the approval
of the site director at dawn noon and
dusk selected celebrants are to perform
scp-1348 II according to present ritual
protocols
at all times ritual celebrants are to
behave according to the prescribed
ritual Purity codes specified in
documents 742 catab and 983 Brazil as
well as additional protocols instituted
by team A
to the extent that such pyranny codes
Conflict by mandating The Forbidden or
forbidding the mandatory celebrants May
register individual ethical preferences
with the site director to avoid
inadvertent ingestion of ritually impure
substances celebrants belonging to Team
B aren't to receive parenteral nutrition
only delivered under ritual supervision
by director
due to ongoing risk of mimetic
transference performance of
scp-1348.2 is authorized only when
necessary for the containment of
scp-1348-3
members of Team B and civilian
celebrants are permitted to exit the
intercontainment area contact family
members or access classified Foundation
documents only upon written permission
from the site director violation of
containment protocols constitutes
grounds for immediate implementation of
protocol 228 melica and transfer of
primary containment responsibilities to
the 228 Malika team
description
scp-1348 is a modified cave complex
located 81 kilometers from El taba Syria
in the jabal aldruz mountains upon
initial Discovery by International
atomic energy agency monitors on 0306
2006 the complex was believed to house a
Syrian reactor subsequent Israeli
airstrikes on the site resulted in the
discovery of three unknown Chambers per
intergovernmental compact with the
Israeli and Syrian government Foundation
agents responded containing
scp-1348-1 2 and 3 and constructing the
site-87 containment unit
scp-1348-1e is an anomalous humanoid
originally observed performing the
ritual practice now designated as
scp-1348 II inside the scp-1348 ritual
complex
on three weeks after initial containment
the subject entered status epilepticus
and died during containment subject
produced three utterances in an unknown
Southern Semitic language but otherwise
made no attempts to communicate with
Foundation staff food water and bedding
were declined intravenous nutrition
proved impossible subject otherwise
exhibited no anomalous Behavior four
autopsy results consult document
scp-1348 smr9
scp-1348-2 is a ritual practice of
unknown provenance spoke in portions of
scp-1348-2 are performed in an unknown
Southern Semitic language when
adequately performed by individuals
meeting unclear ritual criteria
scp-1348-2 prevents full retraction of
the veil surrounding
scp-1348-3 an obligatory precursor event
in scenarios XK 734
xk918 and xk337
at present details of the religious
Faith underlying scp-1348 II ritual
criteria necessary for adequate
participation in
scp-1348-2 and the causal mechanism
connecting
scp-1348-2 with the retraction of the
veil are speculative or unknown
when performed by appropriate celebrants
adequate performances of scp-1348 II are
memetically virulent including
suggestibility religious mania and
desire to perform the ritual practice in
38 percent of exposures
repeated exposure results in ritually
themed obsessive compulsion the mimetic
transmission rate of scp-1348 II appears
to increase as successive revisions
approach the ideal state
for unknown reasons members of haplotype
cmh-6 appear to be immune to the adverse
effects of this memetic transference
while present transcripts and recordings
of scp-1348 II are not believed to be
virulent existing containment guidelines
require certified Foundation linguists
to minimize active exposure to full
ritual recordings
scp-1348-3 is the central chamber of the
scp-1348 complex due to high Neutron
flux the chamber was originally believed
to be a storage site for high-grade
radioactive waste or an unshielded
Reactor Core initial investigation of
the chamber by a remote drone revealed
an elaborate rectangular chamber
decorated in a proto-semitic style
repeated motifs included Rams serpents
slaughtered Bulls wounded Lions Hawks
and depictions of ritual practices
similar to scp-1348 II in the center of
the room is a raised platform with a 9
meter radius surrounded by a cylindrical
sheath constructed of beryllium bronze
at dawn noon and dusk the sheath
retracts causing Neutron flux inside
scp-13483 to increase to lethal levels
performance of scp-1348 II appears to
provide celebrants with substantial
protection against irradiation poisoning
and results in complete closure of the
outer sheath
attempts to view the area within the
chief except by celebrants during
performances of scp-1348 II have been
unsuccessful celebrants including
Foundation staff are unable or unwilling
to disclose the inner Region's contents
for a certified information concerning
the veiled region of
scp-13483 class 4 staff may consult
document 1348 smr-11
addenda document
scp-1348 smr9 postmortem summary
scp-1348-1 D date redacted
begin log
subject
1348-1 e external examination
bodies of taxonomically anomalous
humanoid with pre-mortem history of
severe injury
of the 10 external limbs originally
present three both legs One Wing show
signs of amputation by avulsion below
the second joint
head is presumed to have been generally
humanoid prior to injury with the
exception of a bilaterally symmetric
third orbit located 1.2 centimeters
above the frontal prominence
eyes are missing presumed due to injury
up the canal is present in two grossly
normal orbits
analogous structure present in anomalous
frontal orbit
crushing injuries to frontal sinuses
preclude reconstruction of original
Contours of facial Bond
no external genitalia are visible
injuries show signs of abnormal keloid
formation indicating complete healing
process
external injuries non-fatling
internal examination
structure is equivalent to liver lungs
heart and brain are present kidneys are
absent
gross anatomical investigation revealed
the simple blind God terminating in a
rudimentary cecum
urinary tract and anus absent
as no stomach or cecum contents were
Apparent at the time of autopsy gut is
presumed vestigial
majority of lower abdominal cavity
occupied by a segmented organ or tumor
of unclear function and histology
on histolic examination muscle and organ
tissue displayed signs of catabolism and
macrophage infiltration consistent with
severe malnutrition
cause of death malnutrition
addendum ATP 9 for complete histolic and
gross anatomical data consult document
scp-1348 ATP 9 full autopsy scp-13481de
and log
document 1348 ctl4 containment review
meeting minutes
date redacted
begin log
this is the bi-weekly containment
meeting so
sorry revision a
iding are Dr Benjamin Khan head of Team
a and Dr head of Team B
ready to begin
you'll have to speak up I don't think
the microphone called that
first on the agenda are revisions to the
containment protocol just to catch
everyone up we received o5 approval last
week to pass the veil and conduct the
hypothetical interior portions of the
ritual we're obviously not quite there
on the containment procedures some of
Team B is suffering from radiation
poisoning including
but we don't expect any fatalities Two
omegas Bunch the ritual we're gonna need
to rotate them offline for three weeks
of collation
do we have agents in line as replacement
as you know Ben I'm uncomfortable with
the idea of doing this with Phil Magus
not just because they're hard to train
we've got some feelers out with her EV I
think we have two it looks like we have
two prospects
I think we should be able to move in new
agents as soon as
so no not yet
we've got four Sabian Omega candidates
queued up we've just got to get them
trained in the ritual it's getting bad
in there see if we can speed that along
I mean I'll see what I can do but I
can't promise
next order of business we're going to
need a report on what's inside the veil
as you know
we can't get instrumentation in there
that's not happening put it in Qatar
Team B can't tell you what's Beyond the
Veil told you that's unacceptable direct
from o5 we've got to have some sort of
read on what exactly it is we're
containing in there unless this is a
ritual protocol we don't know it's not
ritual no it's not then you need to
trust me on this put it in kitab Moshe
we're going off record for a minute have
you mentioned turn the tape off request
denied Pro five seven monitoring of
scp-1348 containment review meetings is
mandatory we need to know director
seven they're threatening to shut you
down
how are we supposed to protect civilians
from what's in there we don't know what
that is he's not dangerous look at
yourself the souls and your teeth
they're falling out
and now you tell me that it's not
dangerous how do you tell me that it's
not dangerous it's the ritual then
the ritual
it's not intentionally and we're not
protecting the world from him
we're protecting him from the world you
keep telling me that the mimetics aren't
affecting you but listen to yourself
think about it
you're out here with me
we worked together
you saw what I saw how can you still
have faith with all that we both know it
was hard to have it before
I used to think that there was some
mistake
that I passed the Veil
now I know it's all for the best listen
to what you're saying just listen
it's all for the best do you know what
it means for me to say that to you that
it's all for the best
that this is the best of all possible
worlds that this is you know what we saw
at indara
and I'm telling you that all this
everything is the best we could ever
hope for please please please
don't be hysterical
I know it's hard for you
tell us what you saw
you know what the protocol is of
ISM Team B
you need to tell us
tell us what happens to you is going to
be out of my hands if you don't
understand
when you first came here you asked me
why do you think these people gave up on
their faith
then I know it's because he thought it
best that we not know the truth
and it's true
yala Ben
it's true no one can ever know that we
owe him so much please at least think
about it
I can tell o5 you've got radiation
poisoning I can tell them you're working
on the report
I can't hold them off forever
and log
document
scp-1348 smr11 interview central region
scp-134803
date redacted
background
on December 5th 2011 the director of
c1348b was found unresponsive in
quarters suffering from severe radiation
poisoning upon o5 authorization
c-1348a instructed an omega-class
celebrant to deviate from ritual
protocols and enter the central region
of
scp-134803 after emerging from the
central region subject was unresponsive
the interview appended below was
conducted during a brief period of
Lucidity three days after initial
exposure
playing log now
good morning 9142
the doctors
chapter car
then gone
and you live in the cave outside the
door that's right
I have a few questions
can you answer a few questions for me
but he told me I should trust you
let's start with the ritual
do you remember what you did
yes
they told me I should stand with my back
to the rail that I should say the words
and when the words were over and I had
said
I'll shouldn't look
no matter what I heard and what did you
do I looked
like you told me and what did you see
he's very old
and he's hurting very badly
he is underwater and space and
everywhere else
he cannot get off his chair
he's stuck there forever because he's so
badly hurt on I'm sorry I'm 91-42 I I
don't understand
what did you see in there
I can remember very well anymore because
of the accident
but I remember one time I saw this old
lion on television
on the nature special
he was a bad leader
the other Lions ate him
but I think the line from the television
is in there
I think that lion is your uncle
you've got to think hard oh 9142
can you tell me how it got hurt I don't
know
I think we did something bad
the song is about how bad we are
no that's wrong we didn't do anything
bad
we weren't supposed to happen
we happened
it wasn't our fault that we have I'm
having a hard time understanding
okay okay
the song goes like this
then hey it's all that's it
means he did something wrong
what he did saved us
no no he has to be punished now he has
to stay behind the veil what was he
doing when you saw him he was looking
out
I saw that he saw us
we saw him
others saw him
they weren't in the circle with us
they were standing outside the circle
then we had to sing about how much he
hurts because of us
to make the veil close
so the others don't see him back
they are very angry
they don't remember things for very long
now less well than me I guess is he
dangerous Dr Ben I'm very tired can I go
back to sleep you've almost done your
job I just need some more information
he says he wants you to come home
he misses you
what I think he's talking about your
father
not you
so you don't have to if you don't want
to I I think we're done
you can sleep now
Anna turn up his morphine driven let him
have as much as he wants
and log
document
scp-1348 icl8 incident log date redacted
background
on three days after his interview with
0.9142 and five days after the death of
director site director Khan compiled a
new instance of
scp-134802 and entered the inner
containment area
after performing external portions of
scp-134802 Dr Khan entered the central
region of
scp-134803 he has not been seen since
and the veil has failed to retract
per 057
c-1348b containment procedures are
suspended upon retraction of the veil
c-1348a is to immediately execute
protocol 228 Malika
xcp 1348 icl8
background
on three days after his interview with O
9142 and five days near the death of
director site director Khan compiled the
new instance of
scp-1348.2 and entered the
intercontainment area
after performing external portions of
scp-134802 Dr Khan entered the central
region of scp-1348-3
in accordance with Foundation protocol
for investigating security breaches by
senior staff Foundation internal
security Personnel sequestered all
electronic devices paper files and
personal effects related to Prior or
present assignments by site-93 personnel
after a detailed forensic review
internal Securities preliminary
conclusion was that Dr Khan motivated by
personal stress in the aftermath of the
death of director
spontaneously and unilaterally decided
to deviate from containment protocol and
enter the central region
the following letter was returned
unopened to Dr Khan's primary residence
in Haifa Israel
Judith
it is strangely simple to be writing the
last letter I will represent
as long as I can remember the truth has
had consequences
so I have withheld as much as I could
and now that the consequences are so
very imminent that I will be departing
beyond their reach
I have a confession
when you were 10 I told you that I was a
linguist for The Institute
when you were very young three but this
was true
by the time you were old enough to ask I
was wise enough to lie
and I had other duties
before you retreated into the Torah
when he was still rebellious he once
told me that I loved my country
more than I loved you
why do I have to be a spy I'm not your
father
I cannot answer
because I could not tell you that you
were wrong
I served the world
not Israel
I served out of fear
not Bluff
before the shower your grandfather was a
typesetter and dancing
the Germans burned his press and took
him to monolith
and he walked in the printer shop
after the Americans came he went to
Israel
he fought at Jaffa
and after the war he came to bakai and
then I was born
these were the Great and terrible events
in his life
and I only met him after they had passed
because I only saw the outlines of the
events which it shaped him I could not
understand why he was such a hard man
eventually I gave up I came to
understand that I could never understand
I had only cast my forgiveness into the
dark not knowing what it was that I was
forgiving
when you were 16
Eliza told me that he wanted to marry
you
and the study Torah had been abroad
I screamed at him that there was nothing
in the Torah that he was a fool
I told you that if you married him
I would never speak to you again
I knew then and there that if there was
a god
he was asked
and terrible and blind
you cannot know how I knew this
but I was wrong Judith
what does the Torah tell us
that the name once moved upon the mortar
that he broke bread with Abraham
that he wrestled with Jacob and broke
his thigh that he buried Moses in the
clay beside the Jordan
but now the temple is a ruin
the people of Moses are scattered
and we have lost even the name
for so long I have stood on the edge of
the chasm which separates us
demanding that he explained
when you married Eliza and you covered
your hair
I thought you were abandoning me
but you were seeking after the name
which I had abandoned
I'm afraid to cast your forgiveness into
the depths of the mystery
if you were unafraid even as a child
why have I hesitated for so long
it is late and I'm tired
tomorrow I will anoint myself with oil I
will bathe in the font
and I will speak his terrible name
when the Sun rises I will stand before
my broken father and the fathers who
were broken before him as someday you
will stand before me as someday you will
stand before him
I will be held to account for my absence
I will hold the name to account for his
and I will forgive him
I love you
in light of this new information on the
incident review board altered its
conclusion and recommendation prior to
entry Dr Khan was suffering from
religious mania brought on by exposure
to
scp-1348-2 as a result the foundation
now concludes that haplotype cmh-6 does
not provide effective protection to
Ritual Associated memetic effects
conclusion per 057
c-1348b containment procedures are
suspended remaining c1348b Personnel are
to be treated with amnestics and
quarantined until verifiably cleared of
all memories related to scp-1348.2
upon retraction of the veil
c-1348a is to immediately execute
protocol 228 Malika
this concludes today's lecture thank you
for listening if indeed you still are
and you are all dismissed goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to zargaron
bake sip
oh crap guy
the Morrigan
James Saba
Irish wristwatch
Lost Boy
segnore
your local Foundation agent
zazapan
worthy fire
Dr Wolf 13.
copster
Dean dingus
that loser
casadia cams
braided Peach
GM's right
Rowan O'Brien
cake knock
Grim near
extra moments one two three
and Swift Raw
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you